[Música]
vamos ahora con nuestro primer invitado
del día y el tema es la visita de
Anthony blinken que hoy finaliza a China
Anthony blinken De hecho en esta última
jornada se reunió con ambas potencias
reforzaron sus posiciones pero con miras
a que los conflictos no escalen entre
ellas es el momento más bajo de las
relaciones por Taiwán o por Ucrania y
por otros temas que además incluyen el
comercio además recordemos la noticia
reciente de los Globos espía derribados
sobre Norteamérica vamos al análisis con
Jorge Malena Él es director de posgrado
en estudios sobre China de la
Universidad Católica de Argentina
Muchísimas gracias a usted Jorge por
estar con nosotros esta reunión se
calificó de constructiva entre blinken y
sin embargo que tanto pueden en realidad
acercarse estas posturas
un gusto dialogar contigo Ángeles Buenos
días bueno básicamente Digamos como un
análisis preliminar de estas noticias
que estamos leyendo porque están
transcurriendo en estas horas ha tenido
lugar una muy importante visita de
secretario de los Estados Unidos a China
en donde ha mantenido encuentros no solo
con su contraparte El canciller chin can
sino también con el secretario
exsecretario de asuntos exteriores
huanguis e incluso con el propio
presidente de la república popular China
si chimpín esta serie de diálogos
abrirían la puerta al comienzo de una
etapa cooperativa no tan confrontativa
como estamos viendo en los últimos cinco
años Bueno pero otra de los objetivos
que se había planteado para Esta visita
de dos días es que las disputas no se
conviertan en conflictos qué tan
factible es un enfrentamiento más
directo entre los países
bueno básicamente el el principal punto
de la agenda que afectaría en efecto las
relaciones al punto tal de eventualmente
generar una confrontación es obviamente
la cuestión de Taiwán esto incluso ha
sido expresado
públicamente en estos encuentros de los
cuales estamos siendo testigos en estos
últimos dos días a la luz de que para
china en efecto la cuestión de la
defensa de su soberanía el respeto de
los demás por su integridad territorial
es una línea roja y tengamos presente
que en Taiwán ya lleva dos años dos
períodos Un gobierno que tiene como
objetivo la autonomía en materia de
política exterior lo cual puede llevar a
China a llevar a pensar eventualmente la
búsqueda de la independencia
Mire le quiero preguntar también qué tan
cercana ve usted una Cumbre entre y Joe
biden Cómo se podría plantear este
encuentro
Bueno A la luz de lo que es la actual
Nueva etapa de diálogo sería dable
esperar que en efecto tenga lugar en los
próximos meses alguna Cumbre
presidencial tengamos presente por
ejemplo que habitualmente en noviembre
de cada año es que se efectúa la Cumbre
de la apec es decir del foro de
cooperación económica de los países del
Asia Pacífico es decir este o cualquier
otro motivo bien podrían ser entonces
causa para reunir a los dos presidentes
de la superpotencias Bueno una gran
contradicción alrededor de los
conflictos entre estos países tiene que
ver con que ciertamente se siguen
necesitando no en la estructura del
mundo y en la estructura no solo
geopolítica sino económica parece que al
menos los canales de comunicaciones
siguen abiertos quien perdería más en el
caso de que se cerraran estas vías
bilaterales
sí bien como comentas los dos países en
los últimos 30 40 años han generado una
muy fluida vinculación económica a
partir de lo que ha sido la reforma y
apertura económica lanzada por densidad
pin allí por principios de los ochentas
en ese contexto Entonces es muy difícil
hacer marcha atrás en materia económica
recordemos que incluso en la pioreta
etapa de estos últimos cinco años cuando
estaba Donald Trump en la presidencia se
hacía alusión a la voluntad
estadounidense de un desacople es decir
que la economía estadounidense se
despegara se separara de la de China
Pero por otro lado A la luz de lo que
son los enormes volúmenes de intercambio
comercial entre los dos países es muy
difícil realmente que esta
desvinculación económica tenga lugar
bueno hace un momento usted Nos estaba
hablando sobre Taiwán que evidentemente
es el punto más álgido que enfrenta a
los dos países en este momento usted
cree que podríamos llegar a ver allí
realmente un enfrentamiento o estamos
más bien Hablando de algo como una micro
guerra fría que se mantendrá a
perpetuidad bueno casualmente yo percibo
que a partir de este diálogo que ha
comenzado este fin de semana se va a
desalentar cualquier intento del lado de
Taiwán de avanzar hacia una mayor
apertura de su autonomía internacional
porque obviamente para Taiwán pasa a ser
central la cuestión vinculada con eh el
digamos la el apoyo que reciba desde
Washington Entonces si las dos
superpotencias dialogan obviamente se va
a sentir en la obligación de no
contribuir con ningún tipo de conducta
independentista en la isla pues mire Yo
le agradezco muchísimo Jorge por estar
con nosotros y ayudarnos a ampliar un
poco el tema sin embargo probablemente
los frutos de estos encuentros los
veremos en algunos meses más avanzado
este año es Jorge Malena director de
posgrado en estudios sobre China de la
Universidad Católica de Argentina
Muchísimas gracias gracias a ustedes
Ángela Buenos días para todos Que tengan
un feliz día y también a nuestros
televidentes que comiencen bien la
mañana y sigan con nosotros en directo
América ya regresamos con más
[Música]